et je sais du car est avec nous ce soir
il est chef de l'assemblée des premières
nations au québec labrador bon sens
c'est plus qu'un double cool merci
d'être avec nous mary son hymen 30e le
gouverneur général désigné donc première
personne d'origine autochtone à occuper
ce poste votre réaction d'abord
qu'est-ce que ça signifie pour vous mais
je dirais que ça devenait inévitable
évidemment avec tout ce qu'on vit depuis
plusieurs mois plusieurs plusieurs
années l'hypothèse avait déjà été
évoquée plusieurs fois donc je pense que
aujourd'hui
cette année c'est le bon moment pour
procéder à une telle nomination
et il y avait certainement pas de
candidates plus plus approprié que sa
désignation est reçu commande de façon
générale au sein des premières nations
parce qu'on a vu quand même certains
commentaires de militants autochtones
dire que vont représenter la reine sfr
en quelque part un recul qui s envoie un
message de soumission est ce que c'est
c'est partager sa 7h et l'exil
il y aura des opinions qui sont prêts
partagé par rapport à la fonction
compte-t-il ce qui est le plus
représenté reculons demi siècle en
arrière est ce que ça représente
aujourd'hui on l'a vu dans la foulée de
la grève de la faim il ya une dizaine
d'années de la chef spence l'importance
qu'ils étaient attachés à cette fonction
lors par une grande majorité de première
nation à l'échelle du pays
1 évoquant le fait que c'est à l'époque
c'était monsieur johnson donc est elle
directement leurs représentants de la
reine celle qui a signé des traités
notamment avec les premières nations
maintenant les avis sont encore partagés
aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya évidemment de
toute évidence des limites qui se
rapporte à cette fonction du niveau
d'intervention notamment et jusqu'où le
bureau de la gouverneure générale
parce qu'aussi peu allez donc il y aura
très certainement des défis importants
pour
oui parce qu'elle aura observé un devoir
de réserve dans ses fonctions on parle
beaucoup de réconciliation entre les
autochtones et les allochtone est ce
qu'elle peut faire vraiment une réelle
différence en ce sens à votre avis bt je
pense qu'elle est arrivée au bon moment
comme je lé disque est un peu plus tôt à
1800 m un parcours sans faille depuis
déjà plusieurs décennies plus
particulièrement au sein de sa propre
nation assure inhumé à peu près tous les
niveaux geste du droit international
très très épique et comme négociatrice
au nunavik au tournant des années 70
et puis qui est également au niveau de
la diplomatie canadienne en tant
qu'ambassadrice danemark notamment
d'ailleurs moi je les avais rencontrés à
ce moment là au début des années 2000
donc je pense qu'ils ont un parcours
impressionnant comme personne autochtone
et la réconciliation c'est ce qui est
sur toutes les lèvres depuis roquettes
paix sera dit et je pense que ça
représente sûrement un défi important
oui bien défini des récents gains non
vous croyez qu'elle peut vraiment là
participé à ce rapprochement entre les
peuples
évidemment dans la mesure où on parle de
cette réserve qui est dévolue au bureau
de la gouverneure générale et au moins
cet aspect dans l'eau qui peut sans
doute rapidement atterrir sur son bureau
comme étant une commande importante et
je pense que de toute la filière hauteur
de 7,2 cette opportunité très bien on le
mentionnait il ya quelques instants bon
elle pensa langue maternelle les nos
petits tout elle parle également
l'anglais ne parle pas français mais
s'engage à la prendre quand même est-ce
que
vous voyez ça d'un bon oeil où ça
pourrait quand même lui nuire auprès des
francophones au pays bété sur parts de
be délais impartis évidemment si on
ajoute à sol français d'ailleurs moi la
connaissance pour mes petites que
beaucoup d'autres personnes qui l'ont
côtoyé sans doute mais je sais qu'elle
est qu'elle est très humble et que s'il
dit qu'elle bouge se mettent à
poursuivre ses études en français je
sais que le bol qu'elle voit le font
très bien monsieur picard en terminant
vous êtes en pleine assemblée générale
annuelle
l'assemblée des premières nations ça
commençait aujourd'hui pour élire le
successeur au chef national sortant
perry bellegarde
ce sont des élections importantes dans
le contexte actuel tout à fait surtout
avec ce qu'on vit depuis déjà plusieurs
semaines que les deux couvertures sans
nom d'abord à kamloops ensuite la cohue
6 et c'est pas fini
là tout le monde le dit tout le monde
est d'accord là dessus donc c'était
important c'est important moment surtout
devant des élections fédérales qui
bientôt seront pu tiendront plus de
l'hypothèse donc on a tous ans devant
nous et là je pense que le défi que
présente la nouvelle personne grâce à
cette semaine juste un pic en chef de
l'assemblée des premières nations québec
labrador
merci beaucoup en soirée non seulement
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici rdi